where the federal where the monies came
from
to fund the above budget of the 13
billion
665 million and as you see
federal funds are a very big piece
normally they run around 30 percent this
year they went up to 31.5 some of this
was the cares act recovery funds
that are coming in we don't have all the
american recovery act
um funds yet and we so we can't put them
in the budget we don't know the strings
on them we don't know
all that details but this is because
something you may have heard of fnap
federal medicaid
assistance percentage it went up a
little bit on several categories
due to the cares act bringing it to 31.5
then education trust fund again is a big
piece
15 and a half percent add that to the
general
fund of 25.3 they're also
a major part of this budget other funds
there's too many to mention but this
includes the
tuition in the community colleges it's
fines and fees in some cases it's a lot
of
200 separate different little things
including interest on
on the monies the treasurer holds and so
on
uh liquor fund that's that's the
profit from selling liquor in our state
liquor stores 1.1 percent of the budget
highway fund is 3.6 percent
and fish and game fund is 0.2
turnpike is 2 and a half percent
and that comes in separately as does
sweepstakes fund for
a point two percent so those are the
sources that help make up this 13
billion dollar budget
moving on to page five
the operating budget
of unrestricted revenue again we're back
to the general funds
to show you where we collected them and
what our major
sources of funds are business profits
tax
being the biggest one at 27.8 percent
next would in the business enterprise
tax we usually group those together when
we're doing total revenue
that's only 2.7 about 10 percent of the
business profits tax
liquor sales 8.1 percent
court fines and fees 0.7 percent
securities revenue those are the
registration fees for
mutual funds that want to be sold in our
state have to pay a registration fee
that brings in two and a half percent of
the revenue about 84 million
insurance tax brings in 262 million
7.7 there's a tax on every insurance
policy sold
communications tax that's on your phone
bill there's a couple places
that brings in 77.6 million 2.3 percent
the beer tax it's pretty obvious where
that comes from
26 million medicaid recoveries
that's a complicated uh
formula run through hhs and we get about
6.2 million back from that real estate
transfer tax
at seven percent you'll hear about that
on your county budgets
tobacco tax brings in eight percent that
had a pretty big year this last year
and then meals and rooms tax another
major one 20
of the revenue that comes in so
i like these pie charts because they
give you a pretty good idea of
how all the different pieces fit
together and
where they all come from and where they
all go out so now
i'm going to ask the division chairs to
brief
on the details of the adjustments they
made
in the sections of the budgets that were
in their part of the budget we'll start
first with
chairman lynn ober of division one
thank you mr chairman as you can see
from the division one that's up there
we have made a number of changes the
first bullet point
talks about 1.7 million dollars
of errors that were in the das budget
they were double budgeted for 600 plus
thousand dollars of maintenance to
buildings
if you look at the third bullet point
cyber security was budgeted in error in
their budget which was another 600 plus
thousand dollars and if you look at the
fourth bullet point
there was 517 thousand dollars that was
double
budgeted prematurely for the law
enforcement commission
once we corrected all of those we were
able to restore the 20 positions that
had been laid off
because of the double budgeting the last
bullet point talks about the lakeshore
redevelopment planning commission that
has been
working for a long time on the lakeshore
region facility which the state wishes
to
sell and which would save over five
hundred thousand dollars a year
in doit we restored four positions
that would provide support to conflict
in dra we funded two we're working on
another class
positions that will collect an
additional three million
in state revenue but there's a stream
going on
fully fund flood control programs which
is
1.8 million this goes to our towns
and cities state treasury distributes
152.6 million
of meals and rooms revenues to our towns
and cities
this was an increase of 15 million over
the prior biennium
for this statutory district distribution
we reallocated six million dollars of
general fund
to the department of corrections why
the governor had unfunded in his budget
because of the pandemic where we were
expecting really low revenues
all of the vocational training and the
academic training
in addition we had the treasury talk to
doe
about using vlax our virtual
learning academy for people who need to
complete their high school diploma
because of improvements in our prison
system and the new women's prison
we will now be able to use that we
approve the governor's request to change
the statutory cap
on the rainy day fund the office's
strategic
initiatives and the puc
have now become the department of energy
however the planning piece was moved to
the department of business and economic
affairs
where it should have belonged anyway
we transferred the appropriation for
business transport from the department
of
administrative services to the judicial
branch
and the reason we did that it is the
judicial branch that determines
when prisoners are transferred and how
much security they need
in each courthouse at the same time the
state law says
that the money budgeted will be spent
and if it more money is needed then they
prorate the amount given to the
counties we did not want to cut the
county budgets this will allow the
branch
that does the spending to allocate and
watch the budget we also provided
the supreme court the authority to
transfer funds within the judicial
branch's budget as
deemed necessary this has worked well
in the past such transfers in excess of
a hundred thousand dollars
will require approval of the fiscal
committee just as they do for all
agencies
we fully funded the department of
military affairs and veteran services
including new staff
we also provided that they will start to
coordinate
mental health programs and will
collaborate with the va
there are some new programs being
proposed by the va
that would benefit veterans in our
states
the department of agriculture and
markets and food was also fully funded
and in addition the house passed a bill
creating a database for animal records
for transferring money from certain
funds
this budget makes the required
appropriation for the maintenance of
this database
in the department of justice we
recognize
general fund savings of 278 000
by delaying the start of a new program
and two new attorney positions
in many cases the department of justice
is not able to hire
all new attorney positions at the
beginning of the fiscal year i.e july
1st
this allows them time to create all of
those job descriptions
get the paperwork done and bring them on
at the beginning
of january however it does give us the
savings
the banking department also fully funded
ask that we
change the charge for the public deposit
investment pool because there was a
conflict
for the department's role in regulating
state chartered entities
and the commissioner's role in
supporting the public deposit
investment pool we did support that
in the liquor commission we amended the
state liquor laws i have to thank
representative peter leishman who did a
lot of work in this area
we're going to change the enforcement
division from a quote-unquote police
division
to a licensing and education division
which is what we intended them to be
the uniform positions will end on
december 31st 2021
and that provides six months for the
officers to join other police entities
while fully funding all the positions
that have to be paid for paying
accumulated leave
and other termination costs as mentioned
the department of energy
was formed using osi
and the puc this proposes an energy
department which combines not only the
puc and osi but also the consumer
advocate
and has long been supported by the
consumer advocate is the best way
to go for the consumers in our state
site evaluation committee work will be
done by this agency
and the house finance amendment makes
technical corrections
to the proposed language and move some
position to the appropriate functional
area
it also eliminates some positions
in the department of corrections we
restored the transitional housing
programs at shea farming calumet house
in manchester traditional housing costs
significantly less to operate than
keeping a person
in a prison bed without this resource
there is no way for our prisoners to
transition
back to normal living make sure that
they get a job
take care of themselves this will reduce
recidivism
it restores the transitional housing
program coordinator position and the
operating costs for the housing program
at shea farm
it also restores the transitional
housing programmer coordinator
position and the operating costs for the
housing program
in manchester it transferred the staff
back from the men's prison
in concord to the transitional housing
or to shea farm
restores funding to the department's
educational vocational programs
these long-standing educational programs
at the state prisons have reduced
recidivism and contributed to a person's
success upon release from prison the
goal is
to help people become successful
citizens
and not to return to prison where it's
very expensive to house them
it also provides the department subject
to the approval of the fiscal committee
and the governor and the executive
council
the ability to transfer funds between
and among appropriations
for salaries overtime pay holiday pay
part-time pay
and benefits this language is language
is critical
because we frequently have a high staff
vacant position count there
in the department department of
employment security
assistant commissioner labors asked us
to add the labor's integrity data hub
for the purpose of preventing and
detecting fraud in the unemployment
compensation
and we did that judicial council budget
was
fully funded as presented and it
provides the language that in the event
that expenditures for termination of
parental rights
are greater than what we expected they
also support
indigent parents it's hard to know two
years in advance exactly how much
funding they will need so they can come
to fiscal committee to get more funding
in the department of business and
economic affairs we increase the funding
to the
small business development center they
will now have 225 thousand dollars in
each of the two years
the last year for which they we they
spent money
they spent 160 000 so we funded them
at more than they last spent
we did this by reducing for 400 000
from the money which was 17 million that
was budget for
for travel and tourism in the
department of environmental services
we reluctantly suspended the state aid
grants for the biennium
however we think
that the economy is going to be stronger
than the revenue plan
that was presented to the house by the
house ways and meats
so we added a section in house bill
that will allow the des commissioner to
come to the fiscal committee every six
months
and request unrestrict unrestricted
revenue above the revenue plan
and pay for these grants it was our
intention to show
that the legislature supports these
grants and supports payment of these
grants
thank you mr chairman
thank you representative ober and
division two
chair representative umberger will brief
on division two changes
thank you very much mr chairman
i'll start with the department of
transportation
and this is uh based on the
revenue estimates we fully fund
highway block grants this is money that
goes to cities and towns
and this was budgeted at 68.1 million
over the biennium and in recognition
of the pandemic's impact on the road
toll
and vehicle fee revenue the budget
provides an additional
four million dollars in general fund
appropriation
to this program based on revenue
estimates
again we were able to fully fund
the highway and bridge betterment
program
at 80 million 80.6
million dollars over the biennium this
program
is funded by three cents per gallon
on road toll fees and a portion
of the sb 367
of 0.042 cents restricted toll
and is primarily primarily used for
paving
on state highway systems as well as
bridge rehabilitation and other work
to improve the conditions of the road
system
across the state in recognition
of the pandemic's impact
on roto revenues the budget also
provides an additional 5 million
in general funds appropriation to this
program
we also provide approximately 11.8
million
over the biennium for maintenance and
acquisition
of fleet vehicles and equipment
this includes 6 million from the general
fund
approximately 66.6 million over the
biennium
was allocated to fund winter maintenance
operations and this includes an
additional
4 million from the general funds
we also provide 13.6 million
over the biennium for the state aid
bridge program
which provides a state match for
construction or
reconstruction of municipally owned
bridges the department of education
again the pandemic had an impact on
enrollments but it allows the doe
to make certain adjustments to the free
and reduced
meal eligible pupil counts for the
purpose of
calculating adequate education grants
this would provide approximately 6.
16.7 million in fy 22
and 17.5 million in 2023
of additional school aid to the
districts above the estimates in the
current law
relative to the fy 23 proposed
100 million dollar reduction in the
statewide property tax or swept
it provides the necessary
the necessary requirements for to make
the supplemental
education payments in the event a
municipality's
education grant is negatively affected
this ensures that state aid would in no
way
be impacted by the swept production
in recognition of a one-year lag between
student accounts
and adequacy payments it provides full
funding to school districts
that began full-day kindergarten
programs
in 2019 and and
2020. language included in
hb2 would ensure school districts that
began
full-day kindergarten programs would
receive full adequacy payments
in the first year of the program we also
fully fund aid to the public charter
schools
based on enrollment estimates provided
by doe
totaling approximately 47 million in
2022 and 49 million
in 2023 also
over the biennium we provide a million
dollars for lease aid
to public charter schools and also
increase the maximum
annual aid amount per school from 30
000 to 50 000.
we provide 79.9 million for school
building aid
which includes 52 million
for payments on previously projected
projects
19 million for new school building aid
and 8 million to make accelerated
payments
on previously approved projects designed
to pay down
existing state obligations sooner
and this of course would allow new
building aid projects
in future budgets we also provide
67.2 million over the biennium to fully
fund
the special education for higher cost
students to aid school districts
this is 5.6 million over what the
governor put
in his budget we provide 18 million over
the biennium for career and technical
education
tuition and transportation aid to school
districts
and we provide 1.5 million
over the biennium for the new hampshire
robotics
education development program
in the lottery hb2
authorizes historical horse racing
which is consistent with hb 626
as recommended by house ways and means
which is estimated to generate
18 million dollars in additional
education trust fund revenue
over the biennium for the community
college and the university system
of new hampshire we maintain separate
governance
and state support appropriations for the
community college and the university
system
while exploring a new commission to
study
and assess the potential for
establishing
a collaborative and strategic merging of
the two systems
also we appropriated 1.5 million to the
commission
to carry out its work
we provided funding for the community
college 56 million per year
and the university system at 88.5
million per year which is the same as
the 2021 levels
we also move the administration of the
dual and concurrent role
enrollment program better known as
running start
from the department of education to the
community college
and provide 1.5 million per year
for the program
in the department of safety
we provide highway funds
to um excuse me
provide the department of highway funds
which
is associated with collecting motor
vehicle fees and road tolls
at a level below the statutory limit
which is 26 of the highway fund
we established the body warn and
dashboard camera fund
with the 1 million dollars to provide
matching grants to local law enforcement
agencies
to assist with the purchase maintenance
and replacement
equipment as well as ongoing costs
associated with data storage
this is in response to a recommendation
of the new hampshire commission on law
enforcement accountability
community and transparency or probably
better known
by its acronym leak
we also provided additional funding for
the
department's top three prioritized needs
two positions in the toxology lab and
one position
in the forensic lab these positions will
help to
meet demand and prevent delays and
backlogs
and fish and game by the way which is
healthier than it's been
in years we provided approximately 1.2
million
in general funds over the biennium
and this money 100 000 per year
it excuse me is for non-game species
and 500 000 per year for
uh to help with the enforcement
and the fish and game fund is projected
to have a surplus
of over 6 million dollars at the end of
i'm not exactly sure how far back you'd
have to go
to find fish and game with a surplus
the police standards and training
council
we supported the governor's recommended
funding levels
including 210 000 over the biennium for
purposes of providing
crisis intervention team training
program
and again this was a recommendation out
of
the leak committee and
finally although not agency specific
uh we me we made no changes to the
new hampshire excellence and higher
education endowment trust fund
however it does authorize the new
hampshire college tuition
savings plan advisory council
which you may know as
unique funding to transfer funds between
it and the governor's scholarship
program
which as it deems appropriate and
also we are forming a commission to
develop
recommendations to like
to establish a single neutral and
independent
statewide entity to receive complaints
alleging misconduct regarding all sworn
and elected law enforcement officers
again
this is in response to the leak
commission
and it also sets aside a hundred
thousand dollars
to fund the proposed entity in
2023 thank you mr chairman
thank you mr chairman uh division three
let's start stop there and note that
division three starts with a table and
the reason we start with the table
is because this table tells a huge
part of our overall story of what we've
done
uh in division three this uh term uh
if you if you look to the left you'll
see in the 2018 and 19 budget
where we ended at about 723 million
dollars
and then in the current budget that
we're in
there was a massive unsustainable
unrealistic growth rate of 17.4 percent
so one of the first strategic decisions
that we took was how do we get this
unsustainable growth under control
and when you take a look at what we did
in fy 22
and 23 it's still growing
at 3.7 percent but we did bend the cost
curve down
considerably dramatically but for some
of you who aren't happy with a 3.7
percent increase
let me just put that into perspective
we've had a large number
of new clients enter into
the health and social services arena of
our
state due to the pandemic and so if you
take a look at
client increases throughout the system
you'll see that there's more demand for
services
so so the three percent the 3.7 percent
i think is
a responsible provision of direct
health care services to the residents of
new hampshire
so overall the compound growth rate went
up 4.9 percent
per year so if you go back to the
previous budget
go through the current budget and go to
the end of the proposed budget
the growth rate overall on a compounded
basis is 4.9 percent
i think that's still unsustainable but
it's a good start
in just one budget so on the next
page if we could scroll down to
yeah there we go thank you the
first paragraph provides a lot of those
same percentages we just went over using
words so i won't
re-state all that to you the second
bullet
down where it talks about incorporating
a back of the budget reduction of 30
million
uh even after that 30 million
we still funded a growth rate of 3.7
percent
so what we've done though is we've
set some very clear priorities on what
parts of the department ought to come
first
and we listed them and you can read them
there yourselves
they are direct service provision
so we ex exempt developmental services
including the acquired brain disorder
services and children's
income support services the children's
health insurance program and county
programs
to include the state share of funding
for nursing homes
so so we've set some real priorities on
on where this money and personnel ought
to go
and for those who are concerned that
we haven't given adequate guidance to
the department uh i would just want to
point out
that if you go through the briefing
books that we've been provided
there's probably a hundred federal and
state
laws that they have to comply with
dhhs is not suffering from a lack of
guidance
and and that's before you start to get
to the regulations
so so what this back of the budget cut
does is it says to the leadership
in the department of health and human
services we trust you
we think you're competent we think
you're leaders
we want you to go through and
reprioritize using the
growth and resources that we've given
you
so that we do the most care for the most
number of our residents you get to the
next line
the next line down starts to talk about
a second back of the budget cut
this is a a reduction
on paper it's a paper reduction
otherwise known as a paper cut
and paper cuts they don't hurt as much
as they
actually feel at the moment but
let's let's talk about some numbers that
aren't on here so if you're at home
with a pen i want you to write down that
in
fy 19
the department was authorized 2
951 people
as of 11 march of this year
they had on staff
2 651.
so that's really simple math they were
authorized
300 more people than they've been able
to hire
so so we we can start to see immediately
that the reality of workforce shortages
around the state and combined with the
pandemic
of course and the governor's hiring
freeze has made it
so that the department is
understaffed to the tune of about 300
people based on the fy 19
levels so so
the governor had proposed raising that
to 3226
and it just seemed to me unrealistic
because we still have a workforce
shortage
so we reduced the maximum to
3 000. so that's 350 people
that the department can still hire on a
priority basis
that's 350 people that represents 13
growth in the number of people working
in the department
i'm telling you if you go to any company
in the united states and tell them
that you're going to let them hire 13
percent more people
it's an absolutely unheard of level of
growth
there is no cut there is no cut this is
a 13
growth in the number of people okay
so um next bullet down and i can start
moving from here because those are
really the two big things or three big
things
so we we uh we recognize that
um the department is asking for just an
absolutely enormous amount of money
to replace their i.t systems
and um and one of the reasons they need
so much money
is because they have a legacy system
that dates back to the early 2000s
and it's and it's just out of date it's
out of
maintenance and it's becoming a security
threat
so they're going to have to run some
systems in parallel for a couple years
in order to uh replace and modernize
so so there's money for that we
received very late in the process
a recommendation from alvarez and
martinez to
do some management changes that would
result in some growth
the department had this for two weeks
longer than what they were able to
give it to us so in the last week we saw
the recommendation four of them jumped
out as making a lot of
sense because the payback period on
those was
over 3x the investment in
payback in two-year period so that was
smart
we deferred other parts of that study
because
it was uh we just didn't have time to
redo the
their work and take a look at it so
with the dcyf um
the big decision is that we
uh in this budget are forcing the
closure
of the sununu center in the second year
of the budget
that's going to free up over 12 million
dollars a year
we asked the department to provide us
with some recommendations on how we
could cut
the expenses this facility was initially
built for 144 people and we have a
census averaging between 10 and 16
with a recidivism rate of 60 percent
and so uh so this is expensive and not
effective
um so we need to change what we're doing
and um and so one thing we did was and
we included an hb2
one of the house bills that came out of
children and family law i think either
unanimously or nearly unanimously
that would change the census even lower
to perhaps half
as many kids and when asked the
department
um did not provide what their new
expense rates would be on a much lower
census
and so um so we're just we're just going
to have to try to force their hands
to shut sununu in the second year
now this was a moment of high
bipartisanship in the committee
it was really kind of the highlight i
think of our getting along and
trying to do what's right for the
community so
so the division of economic and housing
stability there
um there's some federal money
called temporary assistance to needy
families
and so we have some parents trying to go
back to work
and there's a wait list for people who
have employer-based
problems with getting daycare
so so this would authorize those
lists to be reduced by using the federal
tanf money
and i think that's good to get people
back to work
so uh the next one down on medicaid
business and policy
we fully recommend fully funded
the governor's recommendations on the
amount of money that we spend on managed
care and fee for service and children's
health insurance plans
so back to the personnel item for a
moment
if you hear somebody saying that there's
not enough people at dhhs just remember
that
almost all the direct care gets
contracted out
the there's an enormous workforce that
you don't see
it's those people providing care
through contracts and and we're not
cutting that at all
we're funding that at a very high level
um
let's see what else jumps out i'm going
to go down to elderly and adult services
this was a major policy move for us the
governor's budget came across
it showed that the amount of money that
the counties would have to
pay for the nursing homes was going to
increase
their spending year to year by about 18
and when we asked rockingham county and
hillsborough county to tell us
the impact of that rockingham county
said that without a doubt
that would raise the force them to raise
the proper
the county share of their property taxes
to seven percent
or up seven percent so in order to
avoid a property tax increase we
ended up funding this aggressively to
where there's only a two percent
uh growth rate instead of the historic
three percent
that had been negotiated in other
budgets so this is one of those hidden
property tax cuts
that the legislature should claim credit
for but
um it's probably going to get lost in
the noise just know that
you're you're helping your taxpayers
right there
um uh
next one down that i think is important
is it's fully funding the developmental
services it's fully funding
the acquired brain disorder services all
of these are coming across
at the governor's recommended levels so
so no cuts it it funds the children
in home support services that the
governor's recommended level two
so there's no cuts then when we get to
the public health
the the big issue here really came
through in house bill 2 where
for years there's been a week
effort to make sure that our family
planning money
goes to council couples
on family planning and and that there's
there's meant to be a a prohibition of
using state
family planning money for any abortion
services
so while that provision has been in
place
um the
the pro-life community has pointed out
that money is fungible
and it once you start paying these
centers
the money is going to help on the
abortion side of the clinic as well
and this has been denied every time the
argument
comes up and there's a claim that
abortion doesn't receive a dime from the
family planning money
well so what an amendment does uh is
says that okay fine
we believe you let's just say that every
family planning program must have a
physical and financial separation from
the abortion services
that way we know that you're right and
what we've heard instead is that it's
absolutely impossible
we're gonna we're gonna hurt poor and
underprivileged women because
uh we're gonna uh separate the family
planning
from the abortion center and it just
can't be done well
so which is it we've heard two stories
with equal passion
so which is it and i
so i'm gonna i'm gonna skip on from
there there's more i could say
but because we're expecting
that there may be a change in who's
providing family planning services
we've put fifty thousand dollars in
there to pay up to ten thousand dollar
bonuses for new awardees
so uh so every every clinic
that's new and get to the family
planning contract
is eligible for up to ten thousand
dollars that'll help them with one-time
expenses
or um it just may be a bonus incentive
to compete
now we've grown the family planning
money this is another thing you're going
to hear that we're cutting all these
services
no in fy 19
we spent 596 000
this year we're following the governor's
recommended budget of eight hundred and
twelve thousand dollars that's a ten
percent per year
growth rate so we are fully funding we
are aggressively funding we are
happily funding family planning programs
we love our families we love our
children and we want to help these young
families
uh bring their families into existence
and to and to raise them well so that's
how we
we've invested in this budget
on the state mental health system
we supported the recommendation
to have some work for uh workforce
enhancements
to re to recruit and retain
uh more workers because they have such a
high vacancy rate there
we've uh also removed from hb2
um a paragraph that basically would have
authorized
a new 60 bed forensic mental health
hospital to be built on the grounds of
the concord hospital
and this hadn't gone to public works it
hadn't gone to
health and human services as a policy
issue
so since it was such a big deal and
because it raised the
bed count from 25 to 60 with no
explanation
and it included some bonding in there
that really is
beyond the scope of what we should be
doing with
uh operating money we we pulled that out
and we're going to on the 12th have a
uh integrated meeting where hhs and
public works is going to come and listen
and we're going to spend the morning you
know trying to really understand
what's been going on and the extent to
which it's been coordinated with the
concord
community
and in order to take care of our vets
we fully funded their expected
census of residents and and then that
concludes it i guess i in conclusion
this is a realistic budget it's got
real growth in it it's got real
priorities in it
and it really respects the fact that we
have a great management team at dhhs
that knows how to establish priorities
and knows how to lead
because there's more than enough
resources for them to get the job done
thank you
thank you chairman edwards and now we're
going to move on to the surplus
statement this is a little bit technical
and complicated
so we're going to call on the genius of
the legislative budget assistant
mike kane to explain page 19 and
subsequent
mr kane thank you representative
for the record my name is michael cain
i'm the legislative budget assistant
i'll just go through very quickly the
purpose of a
surplus statement for the general and
education trust fund as well as the
highway and fish and game fund
is to illustrate that the legislatures
be at the house or the senate's budget
is balanced uh pursuant to rsa 98
b so right here in front of you
it's a combined general education trust
fund in 21
the governor in house finance began with
a negative balance forward from 20 of
about 54.4 million dollars
a majority of that due to the revenue
loss
in fy 820 to the pandemic so a negative
balance did carry forward into 21.
estimated revenues based on the latest
estimates provided by house ways and
means
uh in march i believe was march 18th
as well as a revenue adjustment which is
a restricted
revenue from the education trust fund to
fund the one-time
fiscal capacity disparity and foreign
youth lunch bump
that was provided for the last budget so
total revenues of about 2.78
billion dollars in the house finance
estimates
working with ways and means as far as
budget appropriations
in total uh approximately two billion
seven hundred twenty one
thousand seven hundred twenty seven
dollars in
appropriations that includes about two
billion seven hundred and ninety six
million
in section one which is the large
portion or your state totals in house
bill one
as well as appropriation adjustments
which are in the subsequent schedule 2
again largest one being the offset of
the revenue of the 62.5 above
for the one-time education aim from the
last biennium
that leads the current year balance of
about 66.47
million dollars across both the general
and education trust fund
a cumulative ending balance of about
12.066
million however uh the that is
uh split between the education trust
fund which has a positive 19
um million 896 million dollar balance
it is non-lapsing but 21 based on the
revenues just based on
today uh it's it's assumed that there'll
be a general fund
shortfall of about 7.8 million dollars
if revenues do come in under plan
there's an automatic
or two two triggers that need to be met
in statute
or two instances one being an operating
budget deficit the second being that
revenues
uh for the current biannual below the
planned revenues
and if that were to record that would
require a draw on the rainy day
fund um of about 7.8 million dollars
again a little too early
to predict just based on the estimates
we have today
and the appropriations as well as the
estimated lapse
updated uh we do believe sitting here
today there could be a drop of about 7.8
million but obviously the senate
uh ways and means committee and the
house wage means committee will continue
to look at the performance of general
education trust fund revenue in march
and april
as they develop their estimates for the
next biennium
the balance forward into 22 that's all
the education trust fund as it is
non-lapsing
of about 19.9 million rounded uh carried
forward
estimated revenues including revenue
adjustments from the tax changes
proposed in the bill which were briefly
discussed in the previous by the
previous presenters
results in total revenues about 2.749
billion dollars
in 22 appropriations
from both sources including a lapse
estimate of about 71 million dollars
based on the actions taken by the
divisions
our appropriations about 2.7 billion
dollars for current year
balance of 47.2 billion
of that 60 cent and if you add the
balance forward
the 22 current cumulative ending balance
is 67.1 million
being the middle of the biennium any
balance at the close of fiscal year 22
will carry forward into the following
year so you can see
in the final column uh the beginning
balance in 23 of about 67.1 million
dollars uh estimated revenues again
based on the house ways and means
estimates uh provided for in march
is about two point eight billion dollars
uh revenue adjustments are reduction of
those revenues of about 118
million dollars across both funds the
largest being the reduction
of 100 million dollars in the statewide
property tax the total revenues in 23
estimated about 2.682 billion dollars
uh budget appropriations about 2.830 uh
billion dollars in house bill one and
then positive adjustments of about 17.9
million dollars
um and that offsets appropriations that
includes the back of the budget
uh adjustments that representative
edwards had just discussed
including an estimated lapse in the
second year of the biennium of about
98.2 million dollars
brings the total appropriations for that
fiscal year to about 2.71415 billion
dollars
our current year balance is a negative
32.2 largely due to the
one-time reduction of the statewide
property tax of 100 million dollars
and then the cumulative ending balance
is 34.934
that 34.934 is all general fund balance
at the end of the biennium any excess
general funds will be transferred to the
rainy day fund so that would result
right as we sit here today based on this
proposal
a transfer to the rainy day fund of
about 34.9 million
i'm bringing the balance up to 142.6
million dollars for the biennium and if
we could scroll down to the next
couple pages i'll just show you really
quick on the general
that was the total combined general
education trust fund if you want to see
the individual
general fund versus the education trust
fund
here's the general fund if you look in
the final column you can see that uh
cumulative ending balance of about 34.9
million dollars which is then
transferred to the um
rainy day fund and if you could scroll
down please
thank you these are the revenue
estimates
uh for the general funds specifically uh
based on those estimates provided by
house waste means these are your base
estimates and then if we could scroll
through the next couple of pages
you can keep going there are two
sections on schedule two
one are revenue adjustments as well as
appropriation adjustments so it goes
into detail everything that was
presented to you
in the previous 45 minutes has been
outlined and accounted for
so that all the adjustments are included
and if we move forward to schedule three
this is the education trust fund
and if we look into 23 there is a
current year balance in negative 92.38
and again the reason for that is the
one-time reduction in the statewide
education property tax which is offset
by a general fund appropriation and
transfer of about 65.4 million dollars
which brings the balance to the
education trust one to zero
um at the end of 23. and if we went
through the next couple of
schedules we have the education trust
fund portion
of revenue estimates governor versus
house finance
and if we scroll to the next schedule
four this is similar to your schedule
two for the general fund or all the
adjustments
for the revenues and appropriations that
are listed
i mean you can see the 100 million
dollars on row 11 kind of jumps out at
you
and if we could go forward to the next
item this is the highway fund
it's on a smaller scale than the
previous
but this is a an illustration of the
highway fund to show that
it is balanced based on the house
finance proposal
you can see on row 34 uh 27 about 27
000 is the so-called the gaap basis and
cash on hand is on road 29
that's about 22.5 in cash on hand 32 of
your gap adjustments for the highway
fund which the comptroller
and the agencies work on and those are
uh due to timing or any other revenues
on how they fall within the fiscal year
but about row 34 you
usually want to see a positive or a zero
on that line after you account for gap
adjustments and if we move forward to
the fishing game
surplus statement again this is a
document showing that the house finance
plan and the fish and game fund
is also balanced with an ending balance
of about
um 6.027
million dollars at the end of 23 for the
fishing game fund
and the last schedule
is this just a state aid schedule
something we'll we'll be creating
um we'll be creating this
throughout the session to show what the
actual state aid for 2821 as well as the
governor recommended
house finance uh senate as well as the
final pass
on state aid on a summary level
and that's all i have for my
presentation i know that
kevin ripple is man and mickey are
managing
um the zoom call right now
representative weiler and
if the attendees the house members have
a question
they would like to ask if they could
raise their hand and we could pull them
over
as a panelist and so that the members of
the committee can answer their questions
i can answer any technical question
relative to the surplus statement i
think the members of the chairs as you
have just seen will be able to answer a
lot of the other
questions you have uh specific to the
budget and so
i'll end my presentation and turn it
over to uh represent weiler
and kevin's going to notify you of who
has their hand up
thank you mr cain and we're grateful for
your staff members that
stood by us in every division and every
change and kept track of all these
things so that
we could finally total it all up and
know what we did
so we're open now for any questions from
the house members raise your hand and
uh mr kane will recognize you and bring
you in
it looks like the first person who had
their hand up was representative stacey
marie lawton
and she's a panelist and should be able
to speak now
thank you my question is um
is there anything in the budget for peer
support funding
i believe there is representative
edwards peer support group is
that was that in hhs yeah
are are you saying peer p e e
r yeah it would be in with the
department of health and human services
i you know uh honestly in a
5.9 billion dollar budget i i don't
recall that line item
so um i i i'd taken assist from mr
ripple if he can tell me that we had a
peer support line item in there
there is a peer support line item i off
the top of my head i don't recall
what did that
but i can i can get that information and
get back to you representative yeah
so if you'll send me an email uh i'll
i'll get a
full answer for you alrighty
thank you next question please
the next question i believe the next
person with their hand up was
representative michael cahill
uh yes thank you my question is for
representative ober
about the liquor enforcement slash
education
who will be doing the inspection of our
thousands of
alcohol serving institutions and the
convenience stores selling cigarettes
and that sort of thing
as i said represent peter leishman
worked on this extensively there is
still a great deal of staff
in there to do inspections licensing
and education so we did not
defund the entire group we removed the
ones who are acting as police officers
left the licensors
in there
i know that the department had been
looking for more people to do
inspections
was that addressed the department did
not ask for more staffing in the budget
thank you representative what we found
represented cahill there was a 300 page
uh audit that we all read on this
specific division and they were with
even that 21 people
they were doing less than half of the
inspections they should have been doing
so they were doing other activities
rather than
what we assumed was the purpose of the
inspection division
so that's why we made the change thank
you
thank you mr chairman
and the next question and i apologize in
advance if i butcher anybody's name here
it's
i think it's bound to happen is
representative jackie
grote
thank you that was correct um
this is a question regarding uh division
three
i believe um the modernizing
of the i.t struck infrastructure within
the department
um how much can you speak up please
representative
yes is this better not much
no i'll speak louder
can you please tell me how much money
how much money is being provided for the
funding to upgrade the
um i.t infrastructure mentioned
i believe it was for division three in
the department of health and human
services how much
how much funding is allocated to that
the the totality of the funding for
items services and support in division
iii is spread out amongst many different
lines
the the biggest chunk was related to the
medicaid
management information system
replacement
and we moved that into hb2
and when we moved that i believe it was
on the order
of 35 million dollars over the two years
and and mr ripple feel free to correct
me if i'm wrong it could have been as
high as 43 million
but it was it was a lot of money and
then
they the i.t
budget is bigger than that because they
have
personnel lines uh for it
and they have also uh regular
operating costs associated with with
running and licensing their i.t
services so so all together
if all the different line items were
aggregated
and i never saw it all aggregated in one
place
if if we were spending 60 to 65 million
over the two years just for dhhsit
i i would say that would be kind of on
the low range
and it could it could be as high as 75
million when
all combined does that help
yes i was interested in the medicare
medicaid um
part of it so you answered my question i
have another quick question
may i be allowed to ask it now
it's up to the chairman and i it really
is hard to hear you by the way
okay is this better the uh
the it is is present in every department
across
state government and the employees
are assigned to i.t although they might
be permanently in all the different
departments
so that it can have a universal and
common procedures that they all follow
there's also help desks and things like
that that some of the smaller agencies
that don't have
someone internally can call a help desk
and so all those funds are transferred
in and around government
and so it's difficult to track them
by that one department i'm sure we have
the total somewhere but it it's going to
take a little homework to
to add it all up and uh if you uh
send a query to lba they can probably
get that for you
thank you thank you if i may mr sheriff
if i could receive all of the questions
and then i'll coordinate them with lba
so it's it's to uh jess edwards
thank you for your email i just want to
make sure all the representatives get
their full
questions answered thank you
next next is representative ken snow
thank you are you hearing me yes
thank you very much i am interested in a
bill
and i wish i could remember the name
that was passed last year
in the last session it was some of the
lead
bill and a rather massive health care
bill that we passed
the opening bill was i believe it was 13
59 or 69 something like that
which is a bill i sponsored and it was
about medicaid in and out this would
affect division three
and it was to correct the thirty year
old problem that existed in
the early 90s this program
under medicaid was brought into play for
individuals whose income was well above
the income that qualified them for
medicaid but they had such extensive
medical problems that for example
somebody on that earned ten thousand
dollars a year
and had uh dialysis on a regular basis
their costs out-of-pocket costs
without any insurance would have brought
their income
way down below and what this bill
allowed them to do
is if the spend down was reached so the
spend down brought them down
to the federal poverty level of at that
time it was
591 dollars a month
they they would then begin receiving
medicaid for the balance of the month to
pay the additional costs
this was supposed to be brought into
effect
it was that poverty level that it was
brought down to
was 591 dollars certainly the cost of
living has increased significantly
since the early 1990s 30 years ago
and the intent of this bill was to bring
it up to the current level
so that individuals with these extensive
medical expenses
once they reached the federal poverty
level now the balance
of the expenses they ran that month
would be covered by medicaid
and up until then they'd have to spend
their own funds to meet
but they wouldn't have to go beyond
which brought them down to the level
that qualified them for policy
this is a long explanation does that
make sense does anybody remember this
bill
and why was this not why were no funds
included in this particular bill in
order to
bring this into being was it even
considered
representative snow it's so good to hear
your voice i hope you're doing well sir
i'm doing very well and thank you i i
was
on ways and means last term and and not
paying attention to all the
hhs bills um we missed you
too but if it passed last term
then i'm confident that the department
has
factored in whatever eligibility
requirements that law lays out in
in that the governor's process of coming
up with the proposed budget
made sure that there were funds adequate
to cover that new
eligibility category and in general
in all direct health care we accepted
the governor's budget so
so without being able to be specific
uh i i think we're probably okay
and if if you'll send me an email sir i
i will
work to to find out um what i need to
about the eligibility and get your goods
i will i should just for further
information when i did check
with the department uh and the medic the
personnel the medicaid
they did say that they understood it
they had a plan in place
but they did say that as far as they
knew there was nothing included in the
budget
to cover whatever additional cost there
would be which is
i don't remember the exact amount of
what it was but it's it's not
significant but
their understanding was there was no
money included in the budget to cover
the
additional cost for this to bring these
people back from
a 30 year old threshold to qualify for
care but
i will be glad to send you a memo with
that kind of information
in if you can do anything to expedite
moving that along it would be a big help
it's it's very important for people of
these chronic medical conditions it's
also
a help for people with conditions like
neurological conditions mental health
conditions
where they have ongoing expenses that
are pretty extraordinary and they don't
go away
mr ripple do you know any of the history
on that
i believe uh the representative snow is
correct and that it's not funded in the
budget
if that's the case it also funded in the
governor's recommended budget
um but i would have to go back and check
with the department on the history of it
thank you very much i appreciate it
thank you
next next is representative timothy
horrigan
well can you hear me um i can i could
my question is the governor's budget
included a significant increase in the
legislative branch's budget which
i think is a good idea given um
given i think we've been understaffed
despite the great work you do mr ripple
and all the legislative staffers i think
we don't have
enough staff for enough resources but
i'm kind of surprised that
he would be increasing the resources so
that was he
is that an operational increase or is
that just to pay for
like the things like building new
entrants the lob and then
also i haven't heard anything about this
issue
what's what's happening to our budget
representative oregon the legislative
budget by state law
is handled by the facilities committee
and not the finance committee
all right and do you have any
input on what they're planning to do
here
i do not sit on the facilities committee
sir i do not know
okay i mean i i do not either i mean i
try as best i can to keep track of what
they're doing but um they you know they
don't publish
a lot of information about what they're
doing most of the time so
um so you so there's no comment on what
that was all about or what our
whether uh when we would be investing
more
to knowledge and um you know upgrading
our we we had to do like
i think about 13 years worth of change
in a few months this year which cost a
lot of money but
um you're not coming through very
clearly here
okay i'm sorry i'm trying to speak up
i've been able to hear the people who
are coming in remotely
with no problem and i've been able to
hear you but you're sitting in the hall
so
um so okay so i guess that's about the
answer we're gonna get that
uh nobody knows and it's up to the joint
facilities committee
i think if i were you i would email the
facilities committee chairman i'm sure
that's on the
and with house website i mean they don't
they don't really
post much information about what
transpires that they're meeting so
unless they're actually at the meeting
um it's kind of hard to follow what
they're doing
but uh that's uh okay well i'm uh
thanks for the information then so i
wish okay thanks
next and there are no more hands up
there's no more hands up that's correct
thank you all for your attention i hope
you will support this budget we've
worked hard with it without the able
assistance of the legislative budget
assistant
we think it's balanced we think it'll
fill the needs of the people of our
state
and we'll be talking about it more on
wednesday i thank you all for your
attention